[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi chiedo cosa vi suggerisce questa
questa ripresa questa scena per alcuni
potrebbe essere la curiosità di una
bambina per qualcun altro potrebbe
essere invece link l'incuria dell'uomo
beh allora facciamo un passo indietro
vediamo cosa è successo esattamente un
istante prima pochi secondi prima
quello che stiamo
ecco quello che stiamo vedendo adesso è
un satellite in orbita un satellite sta
rientrando nell'atmosfera satellite
fuori controllo
ok lui sta impattando quei stati
superiori dell'atmosfera si disintegra
un po una volta la velocità è
impressionante sta prendendo
praticamente fuoco diventa una palla di
fuoco quello che rimane in realtà è
solamente una piccola parte la parte più
robusta quella realizzata con i
materiali più resistenti
ecco questo è quello che in realtà stava
guardando quella bimba è immondizia sì
ma è un dizione spaziale quello che
tecnicamente noi chiamiamo space debri
ma se quello che abbiamo visto adesso è
soltanto un evento raro cosa c'è sopra
la nostra testa
quello che c'è sopra la nostra testa
forse per chi non è addetto ai lavori ci
può impressionare perché di fatto noi
stiamo vedendo una situazione che è
incredibile
noi abbiamo dovrebbe partire un video
eccolo ecco quello che stiamo vedendo è
una simulazione realizzata dall'agenzia
spaziale europea ci sta facendo vedere
esattamente cos'è perfetto ci sta
facendo vedere esattamente cosa succede
nella attorno alla nostra terra partendo
dalle distanze maggiori qui siamo 23
mila chilometri
dunque al di sotto anche di quello che
sono i satelliti più lontani quindi
geostazionari se vedete è un caos
effettivamente la quantità di satelliti
che noi stiamo osservando è
impressionante
ci stiamo avvicinando e il traffico sta
aumentando
come potete vedere è ovviamente è una
simulazione ma è quello che succede
realmente perché questo è quello che c'è
sopra la nostra testa
se noi consideriamo effettivamente che
traffico cioè cosa è successo dal 1957
quando è stato lanciato lo sputnik 1 che
è il primo la prima sonda è attualmente
una stima parla che abbiamo circa 20.000
satelli non sappiamo il numero esatto
perché ovviamente satelliti militari
satelliti particolari non sono censiti
ma 20.000 numero che tutto sommato può
sembrare impressionante in realtà si
guida bene ma siamo nello spazio c'è
tutto quello che volete
ok lo spazio è grande ma non è così
grande come possiamo pensare perché da
qui in poi i satelliti andranno ad
aumentare
e cosa succede quando dei satelliti si
scontrano perché dei 20.000 che noi
abbiamo abbiamo parlato abbiamo censito
solo una piccola parte sono operativi
gli altri sono realtà fuori controllo
ecco quello che vediamo qui è proprio
quello che sta succedendo dei satelliti
si scontrano ed erano dei detriti
spaziali
beh quei piccoli detriti spaziali che
noi abbiamo visto in questo momento sono
enormemente più pericolosi dei grandi
satelliti fuori controllo
questo perché perché i satelliti fuori
controllo noi siamo in grado di
monitorarli di gestirli di controllarli
e di eventualmente spostare i satelliti
che su operativi che sono in quell
orbita
ma i detriti piccoli detriti non
sappiamo possiamo solo censirli e
sebbene sia un detrito che può aver
piccole piccole centimetri come ad
esempio un cubo di rubik
siccome nell'orbita soprattutto nella
vita bassa si muove a una velocità di
quasi 30.000 chilometri all'ora
l'energia prodotta l'impatto è
devastante un cubo di rubik e come sono
come 25 candelotti di dinamite così una
piccola sfera di un centimetro di
diametro che equivale anche un bullone e
come se imparassimo contro un pianoforte
100 chilometri all'ora
ecco questo ci fa capire quanto lo
spazio di fatto non è così
effettivamente è sicuro ma perché
abbiamo tutto questi questi satelliti in
orbita perché c'è tutto questo traffico
traffico sopra la nostra testa
beh vi faccio una domanda chi di voi ha
utilizzato una tecnologia terrestre un
mezzo pubblico per venire fino a qui ma
non tanti ma chi di voi ha in tasca uno
smartphone in con quello smartphone oggi
ha comunicato ha navigato in internet ha
consultato le previsioni meteo e magari
è andato su google map maps per
eventualmente pianificare quello che è
la sua escursione di domani voi avete
rimbalzato quello spazio costantemente
continuamente senza rendervene conto è
una cosa che è importante è che se non
vi rendete conto
effettivamente di quanto operata e
quanta tecnologia spaziale utilizzate in
ogni momento
probabilmente no ancora non avete idea
di quanta difficile tecnologia spaziale
perché mandare qualcosa in orbita è
veramente complesso nel nostro settore
si dice che lo spazio non collabora
questo cosa vuol dire vuol dire
semplicemente che quando noi dobbiamo
realizzare qualcosa questo qualche
questa macchina che noi dobbiamo
lanciare deve essere robusta perché deve
ovviamente soddisfa deve essere robusta
per non rompersi durante le
sollecitazioni del lancio ma deve essere
anche leggera perché deve essere
lanciati in orbita
in pratica deve essere perfetta perché
perché quando in orbita
nessuno poi è in grado di ripararli se
per caso qualcosa non funziona la
missione fallita
ecco questo è il motivo principale per
cui le macchine questi satelliti hanno
costi esorbitanti ma la cosa sta
cambiando in realtà perché siamo ci
stiamo avvicinando a quella che una
nuova era quella che si chiama la spesso
economy le spese come cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che lo spazio e sta prendendo
sempre più sopravvento anche dal punto
di vista economico per applicazioni
anche commerciali ecco che allora i
prezzi di questi satelliti tendono a
ridursi ai disposti eventualmente ad
accettare una piccola dose di rischio
magari realizzando satellite anziché
avere il gemello come spesso si faceva
una volta che veniva sollecitato e
spesso distrutto per vedere quali erano
le criticità per poi mandare in orbita
all'altro e farlo volare
adesso cambia adesso ci si accontenta di
qualche simulazione ci si accontenta
eventualmente anche di qualche piccola
percentuale per cui satellite in orbita
eventualmente potrebbe non funzionare
questo serve perché per questo le chiede
l'economia spaziale questo lo chiedono i
tempi più veloci le missioni devono
essere più rapide è così devo essere più
bassi questa nuova spesso economy tra
l'altro riguarda anche quello che è il
costo del lancio perché il satellite non
è solo il costo in sé di lanciare
satelliti no del discorso e satellite ma
anche lanciarlo in orbita
noi pensiamo che se fu un po come dal
fruttivendolo quando si lancio sabelli
the costa un po 3 kg
ecco qui sono i costi come stanno
praticamente scendendo con il più
recente spesse xd al masc quando lui ha
lanciato falcon 9 cv
il costo si è ridotto e un fattore 10 e
questo significa che è un'opportunità
per altre realtà imprenditoriali
avvicinarsi allo spazio perché lo spesso
economy tra l'altro sta avvicinando
settori completamente diversi
quello che in futuro oggi sarà realtà
domani se adesso ha spesso economy sta
già pensando a estrarre eventualmente
dei materiali a
fare degli alberghi in orbita questo sì
è fantascienza forse il futuro ma se noi
pensiamo al grande visionario come
richard branson che è da tempo che sta
lavorando sul turismo spaziale
beh questo è in realtà perché nel 2020
sulla sorgerà in italia proprio in cui è
lo sforzo porto italiano per la virgin
galactic e lì si potrà staccare un
biglietto da 250 mila dollari che
servirà per fare un volo suborbitale
oltre 100 km in quota e per i
privilegiati che possano permettersi
vedere cosa prova un astronauta ma lo
spazio e anche promozione abbiamo
parlato del file con dello space hicks
ecco tutti avranno visto la tesla
roadster in orbita è impressionante
pensate cosa sarebbe costata una
campagna promozionale di questo livello
questa tesla e si avvicinerà a marte nel
2020 ma lo spazio comunque questa spesa
economy
scusate il gioco di parole da spazio
anche le piccole realtà imprenditoriali
anche le piccole aziende
una di queste aziende un'azienda
italiana che io ho il privilegio non
posso dire di guidare ma posso dirvi
coordinare un'azienda che ha avuto
l'opportunità proprio perché accolto una
possibilità anni fa quando una società
americana che ha chiesto di realizzare
un telescopio
noi avevamo tutta la competenza per fare
un tale scopo è sempre stato nostro
lavoro abbiamo fatto danni però un
telescopio per lo spazio è completamente
diverso avevamo assolutamente idea di
come fare però era un'opportunità che
non potevamo perdere la motivazione
c'era così anche la tenacia quello che
ci mancavano le competenze
ecco che abbiamo deciso a quel punto di
vestire su quello che un'azienda per
un'azienda la cosa più importante
le risorse umane in quel momento lì
abbiamo fatto una micro campagna di
rientro dei cervelli in fuga nel senso
che abbiamo assunto degli astronomi dei
fisici degli ingegneri che sono
rientrati dall'estero
che hanno condiviso con noi questa sfida
delle persone che hanno lasciato enti
spaziali agenzie istituti di ricerca
società molto più strutturati affidabili
di quello che poteva essere una piccola
società italiana ma grazie a loro in
questo momento mentre noi stiamo
parlando
ci sono dei satelliti che vogliono a 450
chilometri di quota con cui i telescopi
che stanno facendo il loro lavoro e che
stanno producendo immagini
in questo momento stiamo realizzando
quello che sarà il lancio di decine di
telescopi di satelliti per il 2019 così
per il 2020
noi stiamo facendo praticamente quello
che è una piccola space factory ma
questa space factory non sorgerà nella
silicon valley non sorgeranno
dell'aerospace valley in california ma
sorgerà due ore e mezza qui da noi nel
veneto in questo questa bellissima
terrena grazie
[Applauso]